[Applaudissements]
puis en cours est devenu roi des
yvelines pourtant rien n'a été simple
entre maurepas ce dimanche 3 juin à
maisons laffitte et du en cours tant été
mené au score 1 0 dès les premières
minutes de cette finale de la coupe des
épines bonnet on a été surpris un petit
peu au début de match mais bon je
connais un peu mon groupe donc je savais
qu'on allait très bien réagir avec le
match allait devenir intéressant au fil
du temps donc aucune inquiétude quand on
a pris le but fallait juste qu'on
retrouve un peu notre jeu et pour
continuer à jouer au ballon piqué au vif
du concours réagi pour marquer deux fois
coup sur coup avant la mi temps sur des
exploits individuels comme des matches
retour on finance le punir sur sur sur
des contres avec des pertes de balle à
ses hôtes sa part d'un taux s'avère vite
chez eux on connaît ils ont été hyper
réaliste des occasions de but en
première mi-temps entre rentrer à la
mi-temps on est mené 2 1 mais même on
n'a peut-être pas fait suffisamment en
première mi temps dans les duels dans
l'envié en seconde période les guyot
courtois continue à dominer les débats
se créent plusieurs occasions et
obtiennent un penalty non converties par
les joueurs finalement les grilles
prennent le large sur cette action sans
solution jusque là les murs parisiens
accélèrent et réduise le score les verts
toucheront même la barre dans les dames
car n'évoluera plus trop à du victoire
un peu logique et pas à pas de surprise
pour moi psychologiquement et
physiquement je pense qu'on est un peu
mieux de maurepas sur cette deuxième
partie de saison donc pas surpris disons
qu'on a bien préparé notre match depuis
un moment et puis on les aurait été
super motivé voulait absolument la
gagner donc les gluants courtois
terminent donc leur saison sur un titre
et une troisième place dans le
championnat de première division de
district les objectifs du club sont
atteints et joueurs peuvent maintenant
savourer